mes collègues ici qui tousse à un moment
ou un autre ont eu un mandat local
conseiller départemental de présidente
conseil départemental de mer nous avons
tous été un autre en responsabilité
c'est dire à quel point la situation que
vous avez vécue ou que vous vivez nous
l'avons connu pas forcément de la même
manière mais en tous les cas nous avons
conscience de la situation aujourd'hui
de nos élus de nos collègues je précise
de nos collègues élus dans les communes
et des instants de violence et
d'agression que vous vivez
je ne suis pas là pour faire un
témoignage personnel mais ayant occupé
des fonctions de mer de ma commune dans
le Rhône pendant 20 ans j'ai connu des
moments parfois un peu difficiles
naturellement comme nous tous mais très
honnêtement jamais à la hauteur de ce
que les collègues mères aujourd'hui en
durent et à la hauteur laquelle la
violence
elle est presque dire quelle que soit
les milieux est en train de prendre sa
place dans notre vie publique dans notre
vie tout court et à quel point elle
constitue je le crois véritablement de
plus qu'un danger et doit être combattu
et ce matin si vous avez souhaité que
vous puissiez venir devant la commission
des Lois du Sénat
c'est parce que depuis plusieurs années
maintenant outre le fait que le Sénat et
la chambre des collectivités locales et
particulièrement sensibles à ce qui se
passe je salue entre eux que la présence
de même Gatel qui est membre de la
commission des lois mais qui est
également présente de la délégation au
collectivités territoriale
nous nous intéressons de près sur ce qui
se passe pour nos élus je ne rappellerai
pas
le lâche crime du maire de
signer je ne rappellerai pas ce que
vient d'ailleurs de dire une collègue
mère de Bretagne de Plougastel le
Plougrescant pardon qui a été victime
également d'agression et de tant
d'autres qui au quotidien au quotidien
sont
l'objet de ces agressions
donc c'est notre intérêt d'abord de vous
apporter notre soutien je crois que je
peux le faire à l'unanimité de tous les
collègues présents ici mais c'est
l'intérêt aussi que vous veniez devant
la représentation nationale dire ce que
vous avez vécu parce que là du fait de
ce que vous allez dire nous voulons
comprendre
ce qui ne s'est pas passé
et en particulier nous avons lu dans vos
déclarations que vous avez attendu de un
soutien de l'État je le dis directement
tel qu'on l'a lu il faut que nous
comprenions précisément ce qu'il s'est
passé parce que
dans différents textes récents
que nous avons voté ici nous avons
souhaité
que les préfectures que les magistrats
soient proches des élus locaux des
maires en particulier à leur écoute nous
avons légiférer sur ces points là
que par ailleurs nous avions saisi je me
souviens en 2019 début 2020 pardon 2021
pardon le garde des sceaux sur la
situation des élus il avait lui-même
répondu et pris des engagements
que j'ai à mon dossier
donc ce que vous allez dire n'est pas
pour être retenu contre vous mais
évidemment mais c'est surtout
pour comprendre ce que vous avez vécu ce
que vous n'avez pas pu obtenir pour que
nous puissions ensuite continuer
d'avancer dans ce travail de contrôle
qui est le nôtre et d'une part la
possibilité de faire peut-être améliorer
notre législation ou alors améliorer le
système j'ai été beaucoup trop long
Monsieur le Maire parce que je vais
laisser la parole quelques instants à
Madame maïs Carrère puis ensuite à
vous-même pour
s'y témoigner en tous les cas merci de
votre présence ce matin
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues Monsieur le Maire je me
contenterai de quelques mots pour
rappeler les raisons qui nous conduisent
aujourd'hui à nous associer à la
commission des lois pour vous entendre
Monsieur le Maire nous associer aussi
aux propos du président buffet et vous
apportez tout notre soutien dans ces
moments qui pour vous mais aussi votre
famille sont sûrement pénibles et
douloureux dès le début de ces travaux
la mission d'information sur l'avenir de
la commune et du maire s'est intéressé à
la problématique des démissions
volontaires de mer dont on observe
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui en ce début de
mandat plus nombreuses que lors de la
précédente mandature et nous y avons vu
le symptôme d'un mal-être des mers dont
il nous appartenait d'identifier les
causes déjà au fil de nos édits de nos
auditions et de nos déplacements des
éléments émergent un sentiment d'abandon
un déséquilibre entre les charges que
l'on doit assumer et les moyennes dont
on dispose et l'aide on reçoit et des
relations parfois plus tendues avec
certains citoyens et les causes sont
bien entendu nombreuses et nous avons
lancé depuis la semaine dernière une
vaste consultation Internet des élus
municipaux ouvertes jusqu'au 8 juin pour
recueillir leur point de vue sur les
conditions d'exercices de leur mandat et
leur perception de l'avenir de la
commune elle sera je n'en doute pas
riche d'enseignement et nous permettra
de mieux mesurer l'ampleur du phénomène
et des difficultés auxquelles les mères
sont confrontés mais ces statistiques
seraient bien sûr impuissantes à décrire
la réalité du phénomène si nous ne
disposions pas en même temps du
témoignage direct de ceux qui sont
confrontés à ces difficultés c'est
pourquoi Monsieur le maire au nom de mes
collègues de la mission d'information je
vous remercie d'avoir accepté de
témoigner devant nous afin de nous
éclairer sur le drame que vous avez vécu
et sur ce qui selon vous a manqué dans
l'aide et la protection que vous auriez
dû recevoir puis je laisserai peut-être
en suivant la parole au rapporteur pour
pour des questions suivantes merci
merci bonjour à tous d'abord je tiens
par commencer par remercier en fin de
compte tous les messages de soutien que
j'ai pu avoir de tous les élus de France
en quelque soit le rôle
ça apporte beaucoup de chaleur c'est
vrai
je me suis aperçu qu'en fin de compte
dans tous ces messages des lieux que
j'ai reçu j'ai reçu par rapport à la
date de l'incendie par rapport au 22
mars où j'avais déjà reçu beaucoup de
messages de soutien beaucoup plus de
messages notamment de soutien de maire
qui m'ont exprimé également ce qui leur
était arrivé et notamment parfois les
agressions qu'elles soient verbale ou
physique et puis qui n'ont en fin de
compte n'ont rien fait non pas non pas
déposé plainte puisque à chaque fois
c'est ce qu'il me mettait dans les
courriers que j'ai reçu très souvent ça
terminait sans suite voilà donc en fait
c'est vrai que quand on voit le chiffre
important là et notamment l'augmentation
importante des agressions depuis
depuis un an je pense que ce chiffre est
largement sous-estimé sous-évaluer
puisque dans les dans tous ces courriers
on s'aperçoit quand même que c'est c'est
relativement très souvent et puis c'est
vrai que je pense que c'est pas terminé
avec toutes les contraintes que nous
avons nous a subir les maires avec les
différentes lois et je pense que dans
l'avenir et notamment avec la loi climat
est résilience et notamment avec le zan
on sait très bien qu'on a des des
personnes des des concitoyens qui ont
acheté parfois des terrains à
transmettre pour leurs enfants quand il
faudra leur annoncer que ces terrains ne
sont plus constructibles qui est-ce qui
va prendre ce sont encore les mers
donc dans un premier temps j'aurais
juste rapidement présenté en fait la
commune de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins c'est
une commune de 15000 bientôt 15000
habitants qui est situé donc au sud de
l'estuaire au nord de l'estuaire il y a
la ville de Saint-Nazaire qui s'élève
par sa construction navale et puis et
puis Airbus et puis Saint-Brevin fait
partie du pays grec qui est une une zone
située entre la Loire au nord et la
Vendée au sud dans ce pays de Ré en fait
il y a deux villes importantes Pornic
que vous connaissez peut-être et puis
donc Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
j'ai été élu en 2008 pour la la première
fois donc j'habite Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
depuis 32 ans puisque j'ai exerce la
profession de médecin généraliste dans
cette dans cette commune j'ai été élu la
première fois en 2008
où j'étais adjoint à la voirie au réseau
puis ensuite en 2014 où je suis devenu
adjoint au bâtiment et performance
énergétique et en 2017 mon prédécesseur
qui est actuellement député il y a
nicori a été élu député et donc il
m'avait demandé de prendre la suite donc
depuis 2017 je suis maire de la commune
et j'ai été élu en 2020
en 2016
nous avons eu donc c'était mon
prédécesseur Yannick auy suite au
démantèlement de la jungle de Calais en
fait nous avons vu arriver là il nous a
été imposé par par l'État en fait
l'arrivée de migrants et la création
d'un centre d'accueil d'urgence en fait
de demandeurs d'asile et ce centre ce
centre d'accueil de demandeurs
étaient situés dans une dans un ancien
centre de vacances qui appartenait au
comité d'entreprise d'EDF-GDF et qui
n'était plus en fonction puisqu'il était
plus aux normes
donc depuis 2016 nous accueillons des
ces deux demandeurs d'asile et puis sans
la moindre difficulté alors en 2016
juste avant leur arrivée ça va être un
petit peu chaud quand même puisque il y
a eu comme deux coups de feu qui avait
été tiré sur le bâtiment voilà il y
avait eu également une réunion publique
qui avait permis de s'affronter en fin
de compte les ceux qui étaient
favorables à l'arrivée de ces migrants
et puis bien entendu j'irai les parties
d'extrême droite et qui s'y était opposé
mais le reste du temps ça s'était bien
passé et puis c'était créer également
une association pour les aider et puis
les différentes associations brévinoises
en fait on participait
à l'inclusion de de ces demandeurs
d'asile
tout se passait très bien en
2018 donc j'étais devenu maire de
Saint-Brévin et là c'était le récupérer
en fin de compte certains migrants
certains demandeurs d'asile qui a été à
Nantes et notamment au niveau du square
David de Nantes et Johanna Roland la
mère de Nantes mais avait contacté en me
disant
qu'ils allaient être qu'ils allaient
venir sur notre sur notre centre
d'accueil et là même chose donc
parfaitement accueilli nos associations
qui se sont également occupées d'eux
pour leur apprendre le français pour
leur faire du sport enfin bon tout se
passait très bien dans dans la
population avec ces demandeurs d'asile
en le 11 mars 2021
j'avais invité le sous-préfet à
Saint-Brévin
à visiter un bunker puisque nous en
avons plein bien entendu sur notre sur
le littoral et dans notre commune qui a
été réhabilitée et à la fin de cette
visite
il m'apprend que les États a décidé que
cette hébergement d'urgence en fait
c'est une da va devenir un cada et de
façon pérenne
il me l'a appris comme ça parce que j'ai
même pas reçu je dirais de courrier pour
mal annoncé ça a été vraiment de façon
verbale
le choix puisqu'en plus se bâtiment
était puisqu'il appartenait au CE2
était en vente donc il y avait déjà des
promoteurs qui étaient intéressés pour
pour ce centre
et donc le préfet me dit de toute façon
vous l'aurez donc ici de trouver un
autre site
qui puisse accueillir ce cadavre
nous avions au sud au sud de la commune
des bâtiments qui étaient en friche qui
était une ancienne colonie en friche en
fait avec deux bâtiments et une petite
maison qui sont situées à côté d'une
école maternelle et primaire et puis à
côté d'une forêt la forêt de la piratée
et donc j'appelle j'avais gardé les
coordonnées de d'un représentant de
l'association Aurore qui gère les
cadavres au niveau national et je l'ai
appelé en lui parlant de ce site et en
lui posant c'est comme question voilà
c'est situé à côté d'une école
maternelle et primaire est-ce que ça
peut est-ce que je peux avoir des
conséquences est-ce que c'est un
problème
il me répond bien sûr non il n'y a pas
de problème le fait que ce soit à côté
d'une école et puis
il me rappelle deux semaines après en me
disant qu'il descendait avec toute son
équipe de façon à pouvoir visiter le
site donc c'est ce qui s'est fait et
puis donc ils ont validé ce site de la
piratelé puisqu'il y avait un avantage
en fait il y avait deux bâtiments et une
maison et c'est ce qu'il me disait c'est
à dire que dans beaucoup de cadavres
actuellement en France où il y a un seul
bâtiment il est difficile en fait
d'accueillir à la fois des voilà des
femmes et des enfants mélangées à des
hommes et donc là le fait d'avoir deux
bâtiments ça permettait de faire quelque
chose qui permettrait d'accueillir en
fait des familles c'est-à-dire des
femmes et des enfants
donc ça évolué
ils ont validé
ce site et puis les travaux
l'état également validé ce site et les
travaux pouvaient éventuellement
démarrer très rapidement donc en avril
la première difficulté
dans ce dans ce cas là qui était tout
simplement une délocalisation
dans un autre quartier
c'est que l'État et ses représentants ne
souhaitaient pas communiquer
il ne souhaite pas il ne souhaitait pas
informer les habitants ils ont été la
municipalité et bien sans charger alors
que c'était pourtant un projet un projet
de l'État c'était donc cette première
difficulté on a donc organisé une
réunion avec les parents d'élèves
avec la directrice de l'école avec les
différentes associations on a une
association qui est également au sein de
l'école
qui gère les accueils de loisirs sans
hébergement
voilà on a réuni tout ce petit monde de
façon à les informer de ce projet et ça
a été fait ça le 5 octobre 2021 en
mairie
dès le lendemain parce qu'on savait très
bien que ça allait diffuser il y a toute
vitesse bien sûr
on avait préparé un flyer qu'on a boité
en fait dans tout le quartier
et également avec des messages qui ont
été publiés à la fois sur les réseaux et
sur le site de la commune nous avons à
Saint-Brevin une petite un petit journal
hebdomadaire qui est mis dans les
différents commerces dans les brésiles
moi peuvent avoir également sur le site
c'est également dans ce dans ce bref
info et puis également dans le magazine
municipal de Novembre Décembre 2021 et
puis bien entendu il y avait de nombreux
articles de la presse qui le relataient
peut se passer bien mais pour la
première phase la municipalité en fin de
compte qui a annoncé ça et qui a été
chargé de l'expliquer en fait à la
population
début d'année 2022
on fait des des groupes de travail et
notamment avec l'association Aurore et
également le constructeur cisn qui était
chargé en fait de faire les les travaux
pour réhabiliter ce site et construire
ce cada
et puis là on commence à percevoir il y
a quelque part en
[Musique]
le 7 février 2022 lors de notre conseil
municipal on a validé la vente du
terrain
à l'unanimité donc à l'association
Aurore
et puis ce collectif de préservation de
la pirate les a déposer un recours
gracieux contre le permis le 9 mars 2022
que l'on a rejeté en fait le 22 mars ils
ne sont pas les plus loin le collectif
n'a pas déposé de recours auprès du
Tribunal Administratif bien sûr il y
avait des panneaux de chantier qui ont
été régulièrement dégradés
et puis en septembre 2022
les travaux ont débuté
le 15 octobre 2022 une première
manifestation est organisée par ce
collectif de la Pirée et réuni à peu
près une quarantaine de personnes dont
la majorité proviennent déjà de
l'extérieur de la commune puisque sur
Saint-Brévin il y a quand même
relativement peu de personnes qui sont à
l'extrême notamment à l'extrême droite
donc très peu de Brévinois et très
rapidement ce collectif s'est aperçu que
avec quelques personnes en fait il
allait pas pouvoir faire bouger
la mairie d'autant plus que je vous dis
ça avait été voté à l'unanimité en
conseil municipal et donc il a fait
appel directement à l'extrême droite et
à tous les groupusculte extrême droite
et le 11 décembre 2022 une nouvelle
manifestation est organisée là qui
réunit une centaine de personnes mais je
vous dis toujours très très peu de
Brévinois donc il se réunissent devant
la mairie et il y avait également une
contre manifestation qui a été pilotée
par l'association brévinoise qui s'était
écrit en 2016 justement pour aider les
demandeurs d'asile
donc ça a été voilà c'est bien géré par
géré par les forces de l'ordre qui ont
tout fait pour éviter qu'ils se
rencontrent qu'ils se voient
lors de mes vœux à la population j'ai
rappelé en fin de compte ce projet qui
n'était à l'origine pas bien entendu par
un projet de la municipalité mais voilà
puisque ça avait été l'avant du terrain
avait été voté à l'unanimité voilà en
disant que toute la municipalité bien
entendu soutenait ce projet de cada
et puis à partir de là
ça a commencé donc avec
différents articles sur les réseaux
sociaux
des menaces des intimidations
alors également beaucoup d'articles sur
un site qui s'appelle Riposte Laïque
voilà où on était mis en pâture en
permanence que ce soit moi la directrice
de l'école qui en plus est une nouvelle
directrice qui a débuté à la rentrée de
septembre
la présidente de l'association des
parents d'élèves voilà avec les photos
bien entendu mis sur ce site et puis je
vous dis pas voilà toutes les menaces en
dessous des différentes insultes
ça a continué donc bien entendu on a
alerté la gendarmerie on leur demandant
ce qu'il ce qu'il pouvait faire
et la réponse et vous allez vous la
répéter très souvent c'était toujours
liberté d'expression donc on ne peut
rien faire
et puis ces manifestations puisqu'il y
avait également un projet un peu
similaire à Calac c'était voilà qu'elle
a qu'on a réussi on a gagné donc à
Saint-Brévin et bien on va continuer et
on va faire monter monter la pression et
j'ai reçu moi deux semaines d'intervalle
un tract dans ma boîte aux lettres
personnelle pour bien montrer qu'il
savait où j'habitais de tracts ignoble
puisque je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez c'était en 2014 l'histoire d'un
petit garçon qui était dans une colonie
à Saint-Brévin qui avait été enlevé qui
avait été retrouvé tué dans une dans un
dans une mare à Guérande
ça n'avait strictement rien à voir avec
cette affaire avec avec des migrants et
dans ce trac j'avais la photo de de ce
petit garçon
en rappelant l'histoire et en dessous de
marquer Vlas qui risque de se passer à
sabrevin avec 110 migrants voilà la
semaine suivante la même chose
la photo du d'une petite fille alors
encore plus horrible parce qu'il mettait
la photo avant et ensuite après vous
imagine pas la deuxième photo est
toujours avec ce même discours quelque
chose qui on essaie de chercher c'était
même pas passé en France
voilà le type de trac que j'ai reçu bien
entendu on a transmis ça à la
gendarmerie toujours la même réponse
liberté d'expression
le
janvier je fais un courrier au préfet
voilà pour lui dire tout ce qui se
passait notamment toutes ces menaces
qu'il y avait moi j'avais eu également
une menace ce ne sera pas une tarte à la
crème une tarte aux plombs donc
je fais un courrier au préfet demandant
en fait un soutien de l'État parce que
c'est vrai qu'on se sentait un petit peu
au niveau de la commune de Saint-Brevin
démuni en fait on avait l'impression de
se retrouver se retrouver seul
courrier revenu sans réponse
début 2023 également
on organise également à chaque fois en
début d'année et c'était en février
l'accueil des nouveaux brevinois
et bien entendu on a retrouvé quelques
membres du collectif qui était à la
sortie et qui harcelait les personnes
qui ressortaient avec également
distribution d'un tract haineux et pour
les personnes qui souhaitaient pas
prendre leur tract bien entendu ils
étaient également
insultés ils ont distribué à plusieurs
reprises des tracts également sur le
marché de Saint-Brevin et puis le pire
ils ont distribué un jour des tracts
au niveau à l'entrée de l'école et nous
à Saint-Brévin on a une commune qui est
très plate une commune où il y a
beaucoup tout est fait pour faire du
vélo et on a donc beaucoup d'enfants qui
se rendent notamment en primaire à
l'école à vélo donc ils sont pas
forcément toujours accompagnés par leurs
parents
et ce collectif distribuait ces
tracténiens bien entendu aux parents qui
accompagnent les enfants mais également
aux enfants qui venaient seuls en fait
les tracts étaient mis dans leur
cartable voilà nous l'avons signalé à la
gendarmerie qui était présente sur les
lieux mais qu'il ne sera qu'il ne les a
pas empêché de distribuer ce tract et de
continuer
[Musique]
le donc on a organisé le 27 janvier
une réunion avec justement les parents
d'élèves pour essayer un petit peu de
rassurer de rassurer tout le monde et
nous avons nous avions convoqué à cette
réunion un lieu de temps de gendarmerie
pour que les personnes se sent rassurées
puis qu'ils puissent poser toutes les
questions à la gendarmerie et là la
réponse était toujours la même toute
façon ça ne sert à rien de déposer
plainte nous ne ferons rien c'est la
liberté d'expression le tract liberté
d'expression peut rien faire contre
central
le 7 février 2023
le conseil municipal a été envahi par
les membres de ce collectif il y avait
encore une fois très peu de Brévinois
mais surtout des personnes extérieures à
Saint-Brevin et nous avions prévu en fin
de compte
de faire voter une motion justement pour
donner un petit peu les condamner les
différentes menaces qu'il y avait sur
les différentes personnes que ce soit
les élus également les membres des
parents d'élèves et la directrice de
l'école cette motion était bien entendu
votée à l'unanimité et toutes ces
personnes en fait ben voilà ont insisté
à ce conseil municipal on avait prévu
quand même la gendarmerie prévenu la
gendarmerie au cas où était chaud de
façon à pouvoir les évacuer mais je
pense qu'ils attendaient une chose que
je demande le huis clos donc
comme ils l'ont fait aucun bruit en fait
ils sont restés ils ont assisté à tout
le conseil municipal mais j'ai pas pu
les évacuer puisque ils l'ont fait aucun
bruit
une autre réunion a été organisée trois
jours après le 10 février avec le
commandant de gendarmerie qui regroupe
en fait tout le pays de rêve donc
notamment les gendarmerie importante de
Saint-Brevin et de et de Pornic et
Monsieur le sous-préfet que nous avions
convié
à cette réunion j'étais avec ma première
adjointe qui est aussi avait pris pas
mal de coups sur Riposte Laïque et puis
mon adjointe aux affaires scolaires
puisque bien entendu elle entend on
s'occupant des écoles bien entendu elle
avait été confrontée
à ce collectif
et lors de cette réunion donc on a
rappelé aussi sous préfet tout ce qui
s'était passé voilà
je peux vous assurer qu'on a été quand
même très très surpris
le sous-préfet nous a tout simplement
dit mais les menaces mais vous savez moi
j'en ai tous les jours des menaces
le commandant de gendarmerie
c'est pas grand chose ce sont simplement
des des menaces voilà c'est de
l'intimidation ça ne sert à rien de
déposer plaint toute façon on ne fera
rien c'est la liberté d'expression on a
toujours eu ce lait de motif de liberté
d'expression aussi bien utilisé par la
gendarmerie que par le sous-préfet
donc quand ils sont repartis de cette
réunion on s'est retrouvé tous les trois
avec mes deux adjointe je voudrais qu'on
était un peu dépité un peu choqué en fin
de compte de ce qu'on avait entendu et
là on s'est aperçu qu'on se retrouveait
totalement démuni seul abandonné par les
services de l'État et qu'on allait de
voir et bien continuer à affronter en
fin de compte cette montée en puissance
là de ce collectif
qui en fin de compte ne représentaient
même plus un Brevin mais qui était le
collectif qui faisait venir toute la
l'extrême droite et tous les
groupuscules d'extrême droite
le suite à cette réunion le 15 février
j'ai fait un courrier au procureur de la
République pour dénoncer en fin de
compte tous ces faits
on a repris toutes les menaces toutes
les insultes tout ce qui s'était passé
voilà en rappelant également le
manque de soutien de l'État
et nous avons reçu aucun courrier de
retour de la procureur
voilà
aucune réponse
le 25 février 2023
c'est pour ça que c'est important toute
cette chronologie non c'est peut-être un
peu long mais ça vous permet de voir un
peu comment
comment ça s'est passé
le 25 avril 2023 dans l'après-midi a été
organisée par elle par le même collectif
donc
une manifestation donc c'était une
manipulation qui le déclarait mais on
s'apercevait que ceux qui déclarait la
manifestation très souvent il y avait un
Brévinois et puis les deux autres
personnes étaient en dehors de
saint-briand
donc 250 personnes sont venues
ont bloqué la ville les commerces ont
créé également des
des dégâts puisque bien entendu qui dit
manifestations d'extrême droite vous
avez en face l'ultra gauche également
qui appelle à venir tout simplement pour
se taper dessus
c'est vrai que ce sont des ce genre de
choses qu'on n'avait jamais vu à
Saint-Brévin qu'on avait jamais connu
nous
à Saint-Brevin
voilà il y avait eu le matin d'organiser
par le
les associations qui soutiennent le
projet une contre manifestation qui
avait réussi pratiquement réussi à
réunir 1300 personnes voilà ça c'était
ils avaient organisé ça le matin
justement pour pas être en confrontation
avec les agressions de l'extrême droite
et de l'ultra gauche
le 18 mars
lors d'une cérémonie publique de la
commémoration de la catastrophe du
poivre on a il y a une catastrophe
puisque Saint-Brevin fait partie de la
poche sud de Saint-Nazaire et il y avait
eu une catastrophe à l'époque en 1945 ou
une vingtaine en fin de compte de
personnes
sont décédées dans une explosion et donc
il y a un monument
chaque année bien entendu on fait cette
commémoration de cette catastrophe du
bois avant je me suis retrouvé donc à
chaque fois bien entendu lors de toutes
ces cérémonies patriotiques
les gendarmes sont prévenus
et ce 18 mars en fait après la cérémonie
bien entendu le verre de l'amitié dans
une salle qui était fait justement
puisque c'est pas très loin de cette
école de la piraté dans une des salles
de l'école
et je me suis retrouvé en fait je les ai
vu arriver
entouré par ce collectif à peu près 6-7
membres qui m'ont vraiment entouré donc
je pouvais même pas voilà partir il y a
eu des des échanges et à la fin de
durant l'entretien ils m'ont demandé
d'essayer de les aider pour obtenir un
rendez-vous avec le préfet
donc je me suis engagé à essayer de
faire obtenir ce rendez-vous avec le
préfet
et plusieurs reprises certains m'ont dit
mais vous dormez bien bon voilà j'en
avais pas pris quand je précise c'est
l'été le 18 mars et on va vous
raccompagner jusqu'à votre véhicule
c'était le 18 mars le 22 mars
donc dans la nuit entre 4h30 et 5h du
matin donc j'étais victime d'un attentat
criminel voilà
ou mais probablement un engin explosif a
été lancé mis entre mes deux véhicules
bien entendu ont pris feu et ça s'est
propagé en fait également à mon domicile
et nous étions bien sûr dans la maison
heureusement nous avons été
réveillé par par les bruits et puis
également par trois personnes qui
revenaient de leur travail chez Airbus à
Saint-Nazaire qui ont vu les flammes qui
ont appelé les pompiers et qui ont
insisté
de façon à nous faire sortir de la
maison puisque donc tout était en train
de brûler
le jour de l'incendie ce mercredi 22
mars et j'ai eu bien entendu
plusieurs coups de fil
de la procureur
voilà qui m'a appelé pour ma portée son
soutien elle avait toujours pas répondu
au courrier précédent
j'ai eu un coup de fil de Monsieur le
sous-préfet qui est également m'apporter
son soutien et puis un coup de téléphone
également de Monsieur le Préfet
des Pays de la Loire monsieur rigolo
rose qui était là depuis assez peu de
temps
qui est venu également qui m'a appelé
pour m'apporter son soutien
deux jours plus tard le vendredi en fin
de compte j'ai essayé avec la presse de
lors d'une interview de dire un petit
peu justement ce manque de soutien
d'État seulement j'ai été coupé par la
presse donc ça n'a pas ça n'a pas été
diffusé voilà et donc de colère j'ai
fait un courrier avérant parce que oui
j'oublie Olivier Véran m'avait également
appelé le jour même c'est le seul
ministre d'ailleurs qui qui m'a appelé
ce jour-là
et donc de jour après sous le coup de la
colère donc j'ai décidé d'écrire à
Olivier Véran
en envoyant un double de mon courrier
bien entendu
à Monsieur Darmanin
au préfet sous préfet également au
président de la République
deux jours également après après
l'incendie monsieur le sous-préfet est
allé couper un ruban à Pornic donc pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas le coin
pour aller à Pornic quand on vient de
Saint-Nazaire on traverse la Loire par
le pont donc on traverse obligatoirement
ma commune de Saint-Brévin
la moine des choses quand même un peu
d'humanité il aurait été bon quand même
qu'il puisse s'arrêter dans la commune
pour me demander en fait mes nouvelles
en fait puisqu'il traversait la commune
et bien non ne s'est même pas même pas
arrêté il est allé couper son ruban à
Pornic
le
j'ai reçu alors un courrier également
donc un courrier d'olive Véran qui
répondait pas aux questions que je lui
transmettais dans dans le courrier et
j'ai reçu également un courrier du
président de la République Monsieur
Macron qui m'assurait de leur soutien
mais bien entendu qui répondait pas
voilà aux questions de mon courrier
justement sur le fait qu'il y avait eu
aucun soutien de l'État
le 4 avril 2023
j'étais également additionné par la
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
nationale voilà notamment concernant la
loi sur l'immigration et
en fait c'est cette audition avait été
prévue avant l'incendie et je me suis
retrouvé
donc c'était en visio avec le maire de
bellabre qui lui aussi
à qui on a imposé un cadavre
mais lui qui a la chance en fait d'avoir
un soutien du sous-préfet et du préfet
puisque justement on a pu discuter
ensemble et donc il était surpris moi
bien entendu je n'avais vraiment aucune
aucune relation avec le préfet sous
préfet alors que lui il les avait
pratiquement tous les jours au téléphone
ensuite
et on a reçu comme quoi en fait ça va un
parfum loin le début avril également
une lettre
d'un maire
de le maire de Fameck
voilà un courriers officiel et en fin de
compte c'était une aide d'insultes donc
vous imaginez que j'ai trouvé ça un peu
un peu curieux en fin de compte venant
d'un collègue mère donc nous ne l'avons
appelé et en fait c'était tout
simplement une usurpation d'identité il
y a quelqu'un de sa commune qui a pris
du papier en tête voilà car recopier sa
signature avec le cachet de la commune
une enveloppe de la commune et cela
mettait adressée donc voilà et donc
depuis bien entendu on lui a fait
remonter tout ça il a déposé plainte
aussitôt
le 7 avril j'ai écrit ou ses préfets
pour lui demander en fait une protection
renforcée puisque sur les réseaux
sociaux commençaient à circuler
une nouvelle manifestation qui était
prévue pour le 29 avril
et donc vu ce qui s'était passé j'avais
pas envie à nouveau voilà de subir des
des violences
le sous-préfet m'a répondu le 13 avril
en m'indiquant
qu'ils allaient faire une évaluation des
des risques sur ma personne voilà parce
que j'ai eu comme réponse
et puis pas de nouvelles donc il a fallu
que je relance en fait par mail le 25
avril
et le sous-préfet le 28 avril en fait
m'a répondu donc la veille de cette
manifestation voilà que l'évaluation des
risques étaient toujours en cours et
elle est toujours actuellement
le
7 avril voilà
j'ai été invité par notre ami Joël
guerriot donc au Pouliguen qui
organisait en réunion sur les violences
auprès des élus justement pour expliquer
la situation
et puis
regretter une nouvelle fois pour du
sous-préfet en fin de compte qui était
présent à cette réunion le manque de
soutien il y avait également deux
collègues maire qui était présente dont
ma collègue de vues qui est une commune
à proximité de Saint-Brévin dont le
jugement a eu lieu c'est en début de
semaine voilà dont son prédécesseur
qu'il a harcelé en permanence en fait a
été a été condamné
et puis donc pour cette
manifestation du 29 avril nous étions
aperçus nous sur les réseaux sociaux
qui étaient appelés à manifester en fait
parce que nous avons vu à Paris ces
derniers jours c'est-à-dire toute une
formation
néonazi là de Rennes où il y avait plus
de 100 personnes qui devaient venir
justement sur Saint-Brevin
on avait également l'annonce bien
entendu de toute l'ultra gauche du
pedray de la région nantaise qui
appelait également à manifester tout
simplement pour venir se taper dessus
c'est clair donc j'ai le 17 avril j'ai
fait un courrier au préfet
en lui précisant justement tout ce que
nous avions trouvé et pour lui dire que
ça allait entraîner bien entendu des
troubles à l'ordre public et en lui
demandant d'interdire cette
manifestation
pas de réponse donc
le 25 avril nous avons également relancé
et la veille de la manifestation
le sous-préfet m'a envoyé un mail en
disant qu'il ne pouvait pas interdire
cette manifestation pour des raisons
juridiques ça c'était le matin et
l'après midi nous on découvrait que le
préfet de Paris en fait
interdisait la manifestation autour du
stade de France donc de poids de mesure
même s'il y avait un recours mais bon un
autre ne pouvait pas l'interdire
juridiquement
quelques jours après la manifestation
bien sûr j'ai refait un courrier au
préfet en lui disant ce qui s'était
passé c'était voilà on l'avait averti
voilà c'était quand même le week-end de
trois jours du 1er mai on a eu bien
entendu des dégradations au niveau de la
ville de Saint-Brévin au niveau de
commerce c'était un grand week-end on
est quand même une station balnéaire on
a beaucoup de monde qui vient et ce qui
est obligé en fin de compte un grand
nombre de nos commerces de centre-ville
et bien fermé pratiquement toute la
journée
les dégradations également fait peur à
beaucoup de Brévinois parce que quand
vous voyez dans une petite commune qui
normalement est tranquille voilà arrivé
sans jeûne cagoulé tout de noir vêtus
dans le centre-ville vous rebrousser
chemin c'est vrai que
il y a eu une voiture qui a brûlé des
poubelles qui ont brûlées enfin pas mal
de dégâts donc dans ce courrier je
demandais également au préfet
a annonçait qu'on allait faire
un détail de toutes ces dégradations et
qu'on allait lui envoyer la facture bien
entendu on sait très bien que il
participeront pas mais c'était voilà
purement purement symbolique qu'on
allait également faire chiffrer par nos
commerçants qui ont été obligés de
fermer en fait le manque à gagner
bien entendu aucune réponse à ce
courrier à ce jour
il n'y a même pas eu d'arrestation que
ce soit d'un côté ou de l'autre que ce
soit de l'ultra droite ou de l'ultra
gauche rien c'est-à-dire c'est c'est
manifestants et bien sont repartis
tranquillement chez eux après avoir
cassé j'ai eu le rapport de la
gendarmerie il y a quand même eu 98
grenades lacrymogènes qui ont été lancés
dans une petite ville comme la mienne
donc
qui paraît phénoménal
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
voilà voilà voilà
j'ai écrit donc le 30 avril également
préfet donc justement pour lui dire ça
son absence de soutien et puis justement
lui demandant les remboursements de de
tous ces dégâts
ensuite voyons cela et puis après longue
discussion avec ma famille vous imaginez
que voilà c'est très difficile de
continuer à vivre cela juste pour dire
il y a deux semaines lors du du week-end
du 8 mai mon fils qui habite Paris
est venu passer trois jours nous étions
à la terrasse d'un café le dimanche midi
donc en public et une personne de ce
collectif qui a dit bien entendu des
idées d'extrême droite se diriger vers
moi je l'avais vu arriver mais bien
entendu j'avais tourné la tête pour nous
justement ne pas le fixer du regard il
est venu directement vers nous en
m'insultant mais t'as pas fini de
le bazar ça me réveille tes migrants
enfin bon puis à continuer et puis tout
en continuant en essayant de faire
croire à tout le monde que c'était
moi-même qui avait mis l'incendie donc à
mes deux véhicules et à ma maison voilà
il a fini par par partir et donc j'ai
relaté ça la presse pour expliquer
pourquoi justement on ne voulait plus
vivre ça et puis ma femme pas non plus
rencontrer ce genre de personne et donc
ça a raison pour laquelle on a décidé de
démissionner de ma fonction de l'élu et
de quitter et bien entendu cette ville
voilà qui m'avait accueilli il y a il y
a 32 ans
j'ai envoyé ma démission au préfet
le mardi qui a suivi et en fait il m'a
appelé le lendemain
voilà discuter je lui ai dit que j'avais
pas senti le soutien de l'État ça répond
ça a été mais si on vous a soutenu
lorsqu'il y a eu les manifestations
j'ai tout fait j'ai mis en fin de compte
trois compagnies de CRS pour éviter les
dégâts j'ai envoyé également un sous
préfet d'astre la procureur qui était
présente sur site donc j'ai agi voilà ça
a été ça ça a été sa réponse voilà faut
savoir que le le préfet quand il a écrit
dans la presse qu'il m'a vu
régulièrement au téléphone
le jour où j'étais ma démission c'est la
deuxième fois je l'avais au téléphone je
l'ai eu la première fois le journal
incendie la seconde fois
lorsque j'ai dû donner ma démission
quant à Monsieur le sous préf
je lis au téléphone comme je vous l'ai
dit le jour de l'incendie depuis plus
jamais
donc voilà un petit peu toute cette
chronologie sur tout ce qui est arrivé
c'est pour ça que quand j'ai parlé du
manque de soutien de l'État c'était
flagrant et surtout quand je vois dans
tous les messages soutiens que j'ai reçu
où il y a quand même voilà des cadavres
maintenant qui s'implantent un peu
partout je m'aperçois que mes collègues
meurent voilà on des relations
importantes avec les préfets sous préfet
qui viennent faire des réunions
publiques pour expliquer ce que c'est
tout simplement un cadavre la population
alors que nous nous n'avons pas eu ce
genre de choses et puis ce qui est
désolant également quand vous avez dû
voir la communication du préfet après
après
ma démission parce que je m'attendais
pas à ce que ça fasse des remous des
remous comme ça c'est cette démission
quand il dit qu'il a organisé des
réunions publiques
je parle de la part d'un préfet mentir
et frontalement en public c'est quand
même important je sais pas il représente
l'État
il sait très bien qu'il a pas organisé
de réunions publiques on a toutes les
preuves il suffit de lui demander la
date il pourra pas en fournir il en a
pas fait
donc voilà un petit peu résumé
chronologiquement toute mon histoire
à Saint-Brévin
alors ce qui est amusant parce que je
pense que il y a dû y avoir des
retombées
certains ont dû se faire un peu taper
sur les doigts
sur l'histoire je vous ai raconté avec
ma famille il y a deux semaines puisque
j'ai raconté ça à la presse pour
expliquer pourquoi je souhaitais quitter
la commune
la gendarmerie m'a appelé en disant mais
vous n'avez pas déposé plainte
et donc j'ai déposé plainte voilà
ces jours-ci ils ont même entendu ma
femme qui était présente bien entendu
hier également qui a déposé plainte et
je me suis aperçu en allant signé ma
crainte hier en gendarmerie
et bien qu'ils étaient en train de
travailler
sur les tracts haineux
d'un seul coup madame maintenant on peut
faire quelque chose
sur le directeur de publication du site
Riposte Laïque parce que quand on leur
avait dit on nous dit mais non on peut
rien faire c'est un site on peut rien
faire on peut rien faire et là on a
appris qu'ils étaient en train de monter
tout un dossier pour pouvoir le
transmettre au Procureur
sur différentes choses également
notamment sur les tracts
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure que
j'ai reçu c'est pareil ils sont en train
de monter tout un dossier
les curieux des mois après voilà il a
fallu que tu arrives quelque chose pour
et puis que ça remonte pour d'un seul
coup voilà on prenne conscience que rien
n'avait été fait et puis que la liberté
d'expression va quand même ses limites
et maintenant donc ça bouge mais je
pense un peu trop tard
merci de
ce témoignage
[Applaudissements]
vous imaginez bien que j'ai plusieurs
demandes de parole mais Mathieu Darnaud
notre rapporteur de la mission quelques
questions puis le président rappin le
ministre bas monsieur le kervé le
ministre canner monsieur Bourgy et
Madame Gatel
et Madame ku Kerman après
on va faire la liste on continue donc
monsieur Darne merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Maire à mon tour
vous apporter à la fois mon soutien
personnel notre notre soutien et vous
remercier de ce propos que l'on imagine
à la fois poignant et parfois des
arsenans quand on sait et pour
s'intéresser entre autres sujets de qui
est au cœur de notre mission sur
l'avenir de la commune du maire à ce
sujet qui va grandissant de
confrontation des élus avec une violence
du quotidien en essayant aussi de voir
comment on peut juguler comment on peut
apporter des réponses concrètes on
imagine aisément ce que vous avez été
amené à vivre et à revivre même puisque
vous avez rappelé ici même que
nombreux sont les faits qui vous ont
confrontés justement
assez à celles et ceux qui ont
été à l'origine
des de l'ensemble des violences
auxquelles vous avez été confronté moi
j'ai trois questions assez
succinctes et à la fois pratique la
première vous avez fait état de
l'ensemble
des fois où vous avez été amené à saisir
les autorités de l'État qu'il s'agisse
du préfet du sous-préfet en habitant
entendu que ce n'est que dernièrement
que la gendarmerie vous avez invité à
déposer plainte est-ce qu'auparavant il
vous aviez déposé une main courante ou
j'allais dire été amené vous vous même
ou d'autres personnes puisqu'on imagine
aussi que l'ensemble des élus
municipales
municipaux pardon était amenés à vivre
ces épisodes à vos côtés à le faire
eux-mêmes ça c'est la première question
vous avez aussi fait état d'une
confrontation directe à l'issue
de l'accueil des nouveaux habitants de
votre commune avec
quelques personnes qui faisaient partie
des personnes qui se sont opposées et
qui vous ont j'allais dire à plusieurs
reprises vivement interpellées est-ce
qu'elle a la suite de cet épisode il y a
eu un contact avec le préfet et pour
être très clair est-ce que l'État a
cherché à rentrer directement
en contact avec avec l'ensemble de de
ces de ces personnes notamment pour
expliquer les raisons de ces décisions
s'agissant de du CADA et puis le
troisième point parce qu'on imagine
aisément la douleur de ce que vous avez
pu vivre
feta notamment du soutien psychologique
est-ce qu'un moment donné au-delà des
témoignages de sympathie j'imagine et de
soutien est-ce que vous avez manifesté
une demande de soutien
psychologique est-ce que vous vous avez
vous-même eu besoin parce que on sait la
violence et surtout parfois le sentiment
de solitude auquel on est confronté
quand on vit cela parce que on peut
l'exprimer on peut en parler mais il
n'en demeure pas moins qu'il y a une
forme de solitude face à la violence de
ses actes donc est-ce que vous avez
engagé une démarche par rapport par
rapport à cela en tout cas merci de vos
réponses et merci de ce précieux
témoignage je signale pour la bonne
organisation de débats que si le
rapporteur un peu plus de temps les
autres en deux minutes voilà la question
monsieur Rabat
merci merci madame monsieur les
présidents rapporteur Monsieur le Maire
d'abord bravo pour votre façon
d'exprimer les choses je dirais presque
sans émotion et pourtant on sent très
bien que au fond de vous il y a une
émotion très forte
celle de quelqu'un qui a été bafoué
qui exerce une profession noble dans sa
commune qui n'est qui est rare
aujourd'hui dans certaines communes mais
qui exerce une profession noble et ma
première question en tant que confrère
c'est quel était le ressenti de votre
patientèle si vous travaillez encore sur
cette question et comment comment
l'a-t-elle ressenti la deuxième et je ne
sais pas si je pourrais avoir les
réponses parce que je préside ma
commission dans quelques dans quelques
minutes
il y a eu aussi de la part des
parlementaires et je ne sais pas à quel
niveau mais en tout cas moi je me
souviens très bien d'une question de
Laurence Garnier en séance en séance
publique
interpellant les ministres sur sur ce
problème particulier sur votre problème
particulier je voulais savoir s'il y
avait eu des retours de cela et vous
n'avez pas non plus évoqué votre député
je suppose qu'il est intervenu aussi sur
le sujet et tant député de la majorité
on peut s'étonner qu'il n'y ait pas eu
un soutien plus fort sur sur votre
situation qui qui
au somme de tout ce que vous nous avez
exposé était une situation très très
inquiétante en tout cas moi je constate
une chose c'est qu'on a affaire au
tonneau des Danaïdes à tous les niveaux
sécurité
probité justice mais finalement vous
n'avez eu aucune réponse et on a vu le
château de cartes s'écroulait par
l'événement final qui a été celui de
votre démission tout comme Monsieur le
Maire tout mon soutien bravo et bravo
aussi au confrères parce que je suppose
que ça devait être difficile d'assumer
toutes ces fonctions en même temps merci
monsieur Benoit pas monsieur le ministre
bar ce questeur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Maire je dois vous dire que je suis
profondément indigné
par toutes les défaillances voir les
dysfonctionnements que la chronologie
que vous avez
méthodiquement
exposé révèle et je suis d'autant plus
indigné que voici maintenant près de 5
ans
à la suite de la mort brutale du maire
de signes Monsieur Michel dans le Var
nous avons procédé à une enquête auprès
des maires de France qui a révélé
l'ampleur du phénomène à la suite de
laquelle nous avons fait des
propositions dont certaines il est vrai
on était reprises à notre initiative
dans la loi mais qui comportait aussi
des mesures d'organisation très
importante
et notre démocratie municipale elle
repose sur le fait que tout citoyen peut
devenir mère mais un maire ne fait pas
l'école des mers il n'a pas la formation
d'un magistrat ou d'un sous-préfet et
par conséquent nous avions demandé
instamment à ce que à chaque fois que
l'on repérairait des menaces des
insultes des agressions comme celles que
vous avez
rappelé
immédiatement se mettre en place une
cellule de crise
pilotée par le préfet et qui prennent
elle-même l'initiative de demander qu'il
y ait des poursuites pénales quand des
propos haineux des menaces des insultes
étaient proférées de sorte que le maire
ne soit pas tout seul
nous avons eu à la suite de cette
demande des instructions données au
préfet à l'époque et des instructions
données au procureur de la République
par le garde des sceaux je constate en
vous écoutant que nous en sommes restés
en tout cas pour votre cas dans cette
étape cette fixation terrible que vous
avez décrit
à la situation antérieure ça n'est pas à
vous je pense mais vous réagirez
peut-être à mon propos de prendre les
initiatives vous devez être guidés et
accompagné et dès le début pour ne pas
laisser les choses se dégrader comme
elles l'ont été et c'est d'autant plus
choquant qu'en plus il s'agissait d'une
affaire dans laquelle l'État était
concerné au premier chef puisque la
création d'un centre d'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile n'est pas une
initiative municipale donc tout ceci est
scandaleux de bout en bout je tenais à
le dire même si c'est pas formulé sous
forme de question mais vous pourrez bien
sûr réagir et je suis comme
Jean-François Rapin je peux pas rester
malheureusement mais je voulais dire ça
bien mais merci Monsieur entre les mains
les deux courriers de réponse que nous
avions eu et du garde des sceaux et du
ministre à l'intérieur en date du 7
avril 2021 et du 6 mai 2021 au terme
desquels des engagements ont été pris
qui manifestement à ce stade n'ont pas
été tenu bien monsieur Loïc Hervé
oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Maire bon comme l'ensemble
de mes collègues on est assez stupéfait
parce qu'il vous est arrivé moi il m'est
arrivé des choses à peu près similaires
il y a une dizaine d'années mais j'avais
pu bénéficier d'un soutien
incomparablement plus important de la
part du préfet
et des gendarmes pour faire face à une
situation qui est aussi mettait en cause
ou en danger ma famille
je reviens sur le début de votre
intervention et sur le rôle du maire
dans les questions d'accueil des
cadavres parce que c'était dans mon cas
exactement le même problème est-ce que
vous pensez que
au-delà de l'absence de soutien à très
court terme dont vous n'avez pas
bénéficié que que tout dès mardi ici
c'est à dire que le maire d'une ville
aussi importante que la vôtre c'est une
ville de 15000 habitants ne soit pas
associée
en termes de gouvernance à toutes les
décisions
principales qui qui touche à à
cette question de l'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile sur un territoire
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui fait que
finalement vous êtes à chaque à chaque
fois dans dans un une situation de jouer
le mauvais rôle et et
pour nous législateur je pense que ça ça
et c'est vrai pour cette politique
publique là c'est vrai malheureusement
pour
pour bien d'autres donc ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'important je
pense que on peut voter toutes les lois
du monde elle repose sur des êtres
humains
qui sont en charge de les appliquer et
qu'il faudrait quand même une un
bouleversement intellectuel de
l'administration des concentrés de
l'État pour comprendre ce qui est en
train de se passer dans notre pays et
vous apporter son soutien dernière
question plus triviale est-ce que votre
décision est irréversible
bien merci Monsieur Hervé monsieur le
ministre Patrick Kanner monsieur le
Président oui monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Maire vous êtes devenu un
symbole je crois que symbole défendu par
tous les maires de France avait juste
titre puisque quelque part sur vous la
foudre est tombée alors que beaucoup de
maires essayent de l'éviter dans leur
vie quotidienne
vous êtes représentant de vos
concitoyens
encore aujourd'hui mais vous êtes aussi
représentent de l'état d'être un agent
de l'État comme mère et ma question
porte sur l'actualité de ce matin moi
j'étais très choquée mais je crois que
je suis pas le seul d'avoir lu dans la
presse que le préfet
devait s'opposer à votre démission
dans l'attente du rendez-vous que vous
allez avoir ce soir avec madame la
Première ministre
je ne sais pas si ma première histoire
des arguments qui vous ferait revenir
sur votre décision d'ailleurs je ne
demande pas de me répondre quoi que si
vous voulez la presse sera intéressée
elle nous regarde à l'étage mais en fait
c'est cette relation de confiance qui
est en train d'être rompu entre les îles
locaux et l'exécutif et pas uniquement
sur la faire très douloureuse qui vous
concerne mais sur bien d'autres bien
d'autres sujets donc ma question est
simple c'est aujourd'hui avec le recul
qui est le vôtre
quel message peut-on faire passer à
l'exécutif nous sommes représentants de
la nation nous sommes en faisant des
collectivités locales tout à l'heure
j'aurais l'occasion d'interpeller madame
Premier ministre sur votre situation je
tiens à le dire et je compte bien lui
demander
bien évidemment si elle a pris
conscience de la situation dans laquelle
se trouve énormément d'élus locaux moi
dans mon département du Nord le nombre
de maires qui me disent on en a
ras-le-bol on en a ras-le-bol et
seulement terrifiant ça se traduit pas
automatiquement par une démission c'est
se traduit par une lassitude qui est
extrêmement dangereuse pour le
fonctionnement de la démocratie merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur Seigneur
Monsieur le Maire cher collègue je
voulais exprimer 3 sentiments et vous
poser une question le premier sentiment
c'est vous remercier vous remercier
d'être présent ici pour témoigner malgré
l'épreuve que vous et votre famille
traversée le deuxième sentiment c'est
celui du soutien unanime que nous vous
avons apporté que nous vous apportons
parce que nous avons été révulsés par
les violences que vous avez subies que
votre famille a subi je me fais le
porte-parole de l'Association des maires
de l'Hérault parce que depuis maintenant
15 jours il ne me parle que de vous et
de ce qui vous est arrivé et je voulais
vous apporter le soutien des maires de
l'Hérault je voulais enfin vous dire que
nous sommes indignés par l'inaction de
l'État à travers le témoignage qui a été
le vôtre très factuel c'est finalement
une succession d'abandon dont vous avez
été victime c'est une somme de l'acheter
dont vous avez été victime madame la
Première ministre va vous recevoir
aujourd'hui
elle voudra certainement vous demander
de revenir sur votre démission je lui
suggéré au préalable de faire deux
annonces la première c'est de vous
présenter des excuses les excuses pour
l'abandon dans l'État a fait preuve dans
cette affaire la seconde chose que je
lui suggérer de faire c'est de limoger
les hauts fonctionnaires qui sont censés
représenter l'état dans votre
département parce que la somme de ces
défaillances frisent l'incompétence on
ne peut pas laisser un département on ne
peut pas laisser des élus et des
habitants livrés à de tel aux
fonctionnaires dans votre département ma
question est la suivante dans l'effet
que vous avez subi est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire la nature du soutien
dont vous avez bénéficié de la part
d'élus qu'il soit nationaux ou locaux
depuis l'annonce de la création du CADA
jusqu'à l'annonce de votre démission
merci Monsieur Bourget madame la
Présidente Gatel
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci pour cette audition je crois que
je n'ai pas de question Monsieur le
Maire mais il n'empêche que je prenne
mon temps de parole
je voulais vous dire avec beaucoup de
respect
ce qui est sincèrement mon admiration ce
matin pour la manière dont vous vous
adressez à nous
avec
beaucoup de sincérité un sens des
responsabilités
qui nous impressionne tous et la manière
dont vous décrivez parfois même avec un
peu d'humour ce qui est juste une
tragédie de dérapage
incontrôlée qui conduisent
à pour vous qui vous êtes engagé pour
servir votre ville un moment à devoir la
quitter avec votre famille et donc
Monsieur le Maire ce que je voudrais
vous dire c'est vous êtes où aujourd'hui
nous vivons la conséquence
d'une faillite d'une chaîne de
responsabilité d'une faillite de ce que
j'appelle l'abandon de l'État à côté des
mains ou un état des je veux vous
exécutez vous vous débrouillez et on
voit aujourd'hui ou cela nous conduit
dans une société extrêmement violente et
je pense que Monsieur le Maire nous vous
devons et c'est le propos que le
gouvernement devra tenir nous vous
devrons d'être aujourd'hui la cause de
notre survie républicaine et de la prise
de conscience que partout en toutes
circonstances et sur tous les
territoires l'État doit être là à vos
côtés parce que vous êtes la valeur
absolue de la République vous l'incarnez
la preuve vous êtes aujourd'hui
transformé en bouc émissaire d'une
violence et d'un abandon de l'État merci
Monsieur le Maire merci
à monsieur le Président peut-être à mon
tour et effectivement comme vient de le
faire notre collègue Françoise Gatel je
crois tout d'abord
apporter notre soutien mais vous dire
aussi ma stupéfaction à l'écoute de
votre témoignage
et cela ne changera rien de tout ce qui
vous est arrivé de ce que vous avez subi
mais tout de même et heureusement que
dans d'autres départements les choses ne
se passent pas ainsi parce que si nous
en sommes maintenant à plus d'un millier
de mer qui ont démissionné depuis le
début du mandat il y en aurait bien plus
et donc effectivement dans le témoignage
qui qui est le vôtre
[Musique]
prend conscience j'ai envie de dire fait
après fait d'une défaillance en cascade
qui interpelle très très fortement parce
que
infini les choses pour votre vie pour
celle de votre famille ne se finissent
pas dramatiquement mais tout est
possible et tout est inimaginable et
tout est inimaginable j'ai juste une
question et sans polémiquer est-ce que
il y a il n'y a pas eu finalement une
sous-estimation
des menaces à votre égard convaincu
peut-être un peu rapidement de la part
de certains que ce n'était que quelques
individus excités et menaçants alors
qu'il y avait bien dans votre cas
une organisation
vous les avez cités et une volonté
compris de l'extrême droite très
déstabilisante à votre regard et je n'en
reste qu'à ce cas là bien évidemment je
ne crois que chaque cas est unique même
si malheureusement et d'autres collègues
l'ont dit précédemment il se multiplient
et ils sont de plus en plus nombreux et
doivent nous interpeller parce que quand
il n'y aura plus de mer c'est tout
simplement la démocratie et la
République qui sera mise à terre
voilà Monsieur Jean-Michel Arnaud
oui monsieur président rapidement
puisque leur avance d'abord vous dire
comme cela a été dit par d'autres
collègues Monsieur le Maire en tant que
président là ce sont des maires de mon
département les Hautes-Alpes et
sénateurs
je crains que la situation vous décrivez
soit une situation hélas qui ne soit pas
totalement isolée nous avons
régulièrement des témoignages de nature
différente qui peuvent privés qui
peuvent être politique liées à des
projets spécifiques ou simplement une
ambiance générale dans ce pays qui est
de taper sur toutes celles et ceux qui
ont une autorité
ou leur famille
et permettez-moi de le dire j'ai aussi
une pensée pour ce qui est arrivé à la
famille du président de la République
aujourd'hui dans un contexte totalement
différent mais qui ne mène nature donc
le vrai sujet aujourd'hui est de savoir
comment la République fait face à la
situation que vous avez vécu dans votre
cher avec votre famille
localement il y a 10 ans nous avons mis
en place avec notre association
départementale une assistance juridique
aujourd'hui probablement parmi les
premières associations des parentales de
maire de France notre association a
décidé de conventionner avec un
psychologue pour pouvoir faire un
accompagnement aussi des mères
confrontés à des difficultés et à des
tragédies parfois locales mais souvent
aussi intimes parce qu'il faut vivre
cette situation là en lien avec sa
famille et bien souvent d'ailleurs le
dispositif de bascule quand le maire
lâche peut-être à ce vocable vous le
direz vous le direz pas je respecte
évidemment votre intimité c'est aussi
protéger sa famille parce que les élus
ont des familles et des familles n'ont
pas choisi forcément l'engagement de
leur de leur père de leur mère mais sont
exposés tout autant ma question est la
suivante pensez-vous au vu d'autres
expériences
qu'il s'agit d'une chaîne de défaillance
individuelle
ou d'un système puisque vous avez
l'expérience d'élus une expérience déjà
riche
un déficit finalement l'organisation de
la réponse institutionnelle des
institutions républicaines à l'égard
d'un maire à l'égard d'un élu à l'égard
d'une personne ayant autorité qui se
trouve confrontée à du harcèlement enfin
je tiens aussi à le dire nous avons
probablement dans votre expérience comme
beaucoup d'expérience que nous avons
vécues dans nos départements respectifs
du harcèlement aussi lié aux réseaux
sociaux et à des groupes extrêmement
organisés j'aimerais éventuellement que
vous puissiez nous dire ce que vous en
pensez parce que bien souvent le
harcèlement se fait moins sur la
proximité puisqu'on est à portée de
connexion de nos collectivités de nos
collègues et de nos concitoyens mais par
contre on est à porter aussi de
connexion de tout ce qui fait
effectivement
qu'une république est aujourd'hui
bafouée que ces représentants notamment
les mers dans la petite république
constituent la commune
ressent de manière peut-être plus vive
alors je crois qu'il y a aussi
d'un point de législatif d'un point de
vue message politique à adressé aussi un
élément fort pour que je stoppe le
harcèlement et les organisations de
masse et parfois vous avez cité une
association qui est spécialiste en la
matière du harcèlement visé et ciblé
pour faire craquer la démocratie locale
merci Monsieur Joël guerriot
et puis madame belleriti
oui merci président
le 7 avril lorsque j'avais organisé
cette réunion autour de la violence
faite aux élus il y avait pratiquement
50 un peu plus de 50 élus pour la
plupart des maires qui avaient été
eux-mêmes victimes de d'une situation
d'agressivité d'agression de violence et
moi ce qui m'a marqué beaucoup Yannick
lors de ta de ton témoignage ça a été la
présentation de ce fameux tract ou des
différents tracks mais surtout l'un
d'entre eux que tu as particulièrement
décrit tout à l'heure qui est d'une
violence extrême mais surtout qui expose
nos propres nos proches et je pense que
dès l'instant où nos proches se trouvent
en danger alors que c'est finalement
notre engagement à nous qui nous conduit
à exercer une fonction qui est la nôtre
je trouve que le dès l'instant où nos
proches se trouvent en situation d'être
eux-mêmes les victimes ou du moins et
d'être agressés et de de sentir que
finalement on prend des risques pour eux
je pense que ça nous amène à une
décision telle que celle que tu as pu
prendre
et c'est difficilement
irréversible parce que on peut pas
mettre en danger sa famille ça me paraît
être extrêmement compliqué et c'est là
que je comprends pas la réaction de nos
forces de l'ordre je comprends pas la
réalité réactions que vous qui vous
l'absence plutôt de réaction face à
cette à ce type d'acte qui finalement
déclare par de fait même une menace
inacceptable quoi odieuse
invraisemblable donc si tu peux nous en
parler un peu plus non pas de ce trac
mais de la façon dont ça a été vécu et
en particulier par tes proches
merci Madame belriti puis Monsieur
kerouge Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Maire je voudrais tout
d'abord vous remercier et vous féliciter
car vous avez le courage aujourd'hui de
dénoncer un sentiment qui est devenu
général auprès des maires c'est celui de
l'abandon de la part de l'État dans mon
département nous avons eu une dizaine de
cas pratiquement similaire au vote et
aujourd'hui et bien on a une réponse
extrêmement légère de la part de la
justice par votre décision de
d'abandonner votre mandat et bien vous
souhaitez déclencher une prise de
considération réelle de l'État je
l'espère que cela
servira en tout cas sachez que le 13
avril dernier j'ai interpellé le
gouvernement sur la recrudescence des
violences faites au mères madame la
ministre fort m'avait affirmé à ce
moment-là qu'elle mettrait en place des
mesures c'était le 13 avril dernier et
je crois que rien n'a été fait alors
voilà aujourd'hui
face à tout cela et bien cela renvoie
l'incapacité chronique de réaffirmer
l'autorité de l'État et moi ce que
j'aimerais savoir c'est pensez-vous que
la justice
des réponses à la hauteur envers ses
agresseurs
merci madame Monsieur Eric Hero je suis
le ministre sueur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Maire d'abord merci de votre témoignage
aujourd'hui parce que je pense que vous
êtes devenus un symbole d'une certaine
façon à votre insu et je pense pas que
ce soit facile d'être dans cette dans
cette situation après les événements que
vous avez que vous avez traversé il y a
plusieurs problèmes dans votre cas le
premier c'est que il y a une
recrudescence manifeste des exactions de
l'extrême droite et de l'ultra droite en
France chez vous comme il y a pu en
avoir ailleurs vous avez rappelé un
Calac à Lille autour du bar citadelle ou
encore à Lyon la question c'est de
savoir si effectivement
on peut avoir trop de complaisance
politiques par rapport à ces exactions
ou s'il faut réagir parce qu'elle
remette en question la démocratie
singulièrement la démocratie locale et
c'est ce qui s'est passé chez vous
la deuxième point c'est que
effectivement cette
pas comment le qualifier mais cette
protestation politique extrémiste c'est
incarné contre vous et votre équipe et
votre équipe municipale en remettant en
cause la démocratie locale que que vous
incarnez et on en vient à un point qu'on
évoque régulièrement au Sénat c'est
celui de la protection des élus du
statut des élus entendu au sens large de
telle façon à ce que il ne se retrouve
pas seul trop seul devant les situations
qu'ils ont à affronter et manifestement
ce que vous avez décrit c'est exactement
ça c'est aussi l'histoire d'une solitude
par rapport à un état qui n'a pas a
priori répondu du tout comme il aurait
voulu le faire alors ma question elle
est assez simple selon vous
qu'est-ce qui a manqué comme réponse de
quoi auriez-vous eu besoin pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir continuer et affronter
cette situation ou pour le coup vous
vous êtes retrouvé seul vous et votre
équipe avec les conséquences qui ont été
évoquées malheureusement sur votre
famille et le débordement complet sur
votre sur votre vie privée
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Maire chers collègues
ce que vous avez dit est factuel
et le défilé de tout ce que vous avez
décrit jour après jour et beaucoup plus
éloquent que de grandes déclarations
parce qu'on a vu exactement votre vécu
et à cet égard on va tous vous dire bien
sûr notre total soutien mais cela n'a de
sens que si il y a des choses qui
changent
lorsqu'il y a eu la mort du maire de
signes on avait fait un rapport comme tu
l'as rappelé et on a on a dit plus
jamais ça
et là qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
finalement on imagine le des services de
l'État une préfecture une
sous-préfecture bon il y a tellement de
problèmes on parle des manifestations à
Nantes à Rennes à Paris etc bon voilà
Saint-Brevin bon mais eux d'une certaine
façon de traite pas véritablement la
chose parce que il y a une sorte de
routine et ce qui est devenu
inacceptable c'est que face à la
question du droit d'asile qui est un
droit qui est l'honneur de la République
d'accueillir les gens qui sont
persécutés
et c'est quelque chose d'absolument
fondamental il y a un racisme banal qui
se développe à une très grande rapidité
et ça c'est une honte pour la France
alors ce qu'il faut maintenant
c'est un changement de cap de telle
manière que le moindre fait
soit traité qu'il y ait réponse et non
pas empilement des papiers pour vous
dire voilà on a reçu votre papier on est
on fait des on s'en occupe mais en fait
on ne s'en occupe pas il faut qu'il y
ait un coup d'arrêt moi je ressens ça
tellement fortement un coup d'arrêt et
ça appelle beaucoup de choses y compris
dans nos comportements aux uns et aux
autres que l'on ne reste jamais passif
devant ce qui est en train de se passer
voyez-vous j'ai été frappé quant à
l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde
s'est levé pour vous applaudir sauf ceux
qui sont restés assis
et
ça veut dire beaucoup parce que
ils sont restés assis devant la violence
faite à un maire
mais devant la violence faite à un maire
qui applique la loi de la République qui
est d'accueillir ceux qui sont
persécutés donc moi je voulais vous dire
un grand merci bon bravo mais tous ces
paroles n'ont de sens que si à partir
d'aujourd'hui cet après-midi on va voir
l'occasion d'en parler mais il y a dans
cette république un sursaut pour
agir dès qu'il y a la moindre chose
parce que la moindre chose c'est quand
même beaucoup trop tous les tracts les
papiers etc il y a des tracts on doit
réagir on ne peut pas ne pas réagir et
bien sûr l'incendie tout ça comment cela
n'a pas pu donner lieu à des réactions
plus fortes donc je crois que notre
soutien est un devoir pour nous tous de
demander que ça change
[Musique]
voyez puis ensuite la parole
Yannick Moret
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues Monsieur le Maire je
voudrais très brièvement vous dire à mon
tour tout le soutien qui est le mien et
effectivement
à peine élu c'est pas sénateur j'ai
entendu
un ministre proposé à l'instant maire ce
qui a commencé à créer peut-être auprès
des mers un climat particulièrement
délétère mais effectivement je crois
qu'en tant qu'élume malheureusement dans
nos fonctions précédentes ou dans nos
fonctions actuelles on a tous été
confrontés directement ou indirectement
à de la violence et on assiste
aujourd'hui à une contestation de tout
ce qui peut ressembler à une figure
d'autorité ou de réussite ou de nantis
et avec des personnes qui
souhaitent faire plier la République et
c'est vrai que c'est particulièrement
dangereux et je dois vous dire Monsieur
le Maire il y a quelques semaines dans
les Bouches-du-Rhône l'initiative du
président de l'Association des Maires et
de la présidente du département nous
avons une très grande réunion avec tous
les maires du département et
les sénateurs les députés mais aussi
toutes les figures d'autorité de l'État
et la question des violences a été
évoquée par nombreux de nombreux mères
qui avaient été confrontés effectivement
à des agressions et ils ont été incités
à déposer plainte et quand
j'entends
j'entends votre témoignage
vous qui êtes aujourd'hui à la fois
devenu le symbole de ces dévalences de
ces défaillances des réponses de
l'autorité publique des agressions mais
aussi du courage des élus
et moi aussi j'étais stupéfaite en
entendant le détail de votre témoignage
parce qu'on se dit c'est pas possible un
moment donné ça va bien finir par
s'arrêter je voudrais savoir
si vous pensez que
l'inaction est liée à l'affaissement de
la réponse publique et des services
publics d'une part et d'autre part
à votre avis qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
pour que la réponse soit à la fois
effective et efficace je vous remercie
merci Madame bien dans la liste de
questions
vous répondez dans l'ordre que vous
voulez la manière dont vous souhaitez
naturellement mais vous avez seul la
parole
merci
pour répondre donc la liste des
questions il y a eu des personnes qui
ont déposé plainte et je pense notamment
à la directrice de l'école d'une part et
puis également à la présidente de
l'association des parents d'élèves qu'on
réussit à déposer plainte en fait mais
parce qu'on était derrière qu'on leur a
demandé à tout prix de le faire parce
que c'est vrai que elles ne se sont pas
des élus voilà
elles sont là notamment la directrice
voilà pour assumer son rôle de vérifier
d'école et l'association des parents
d'élèves la Présidente c'est pareil
c'est voilà donc là on les a
on dirait aider dans le sens où il
fallait à tout prix qu'elle dépose une
plainte et donc la plainte avait été
enregistrée tout à l'heure j'ai dit que
également que le collectif avait demandé
m'avait demandé à tout prix à ce que je
puisse les aider pour obtenir un
rendez-vous avec le préfet il a fallu
que je relance plusieurs fois le préfet
parce que ça devenait toujours pas et
la la veille de la dernière
manifestation
j'ai reçu un mail comme quoi il avait
été reçu quelques jours auparavant
simplement
qu'ils avaient été reçus par le
secrétaire général de la préfecture donc
et puis il y a eu plusieurs également
interventions sur l'aspect psychologique
alors j'ai beaucoup de chance puisque
j'ai pas du tout un tempérament anxieux
voilà donc moi tout me passe par dessus
voilà je subis sans sans problème
toutes les attaques toutes les
insultes mais là quand même j'ai pris un
coup sur la tête le jour où c'est arrivé
le matin même je me demandais si c'était
pas un cauchemar j'étais en train de
vivre donc quand je me suis retrouvé 5
heures du matin avec mon épouse en train
de voir mes voitures brûlées et puis et
puis la maison également prendre feu
donc voilà ce sont complètement démunis
en plus à cette heure là bien entendu
vous imaginez les pompiers ne mettent
pas de sirène donc je peux vous assurer
qu'on trouve le temps vraiment très très
long
donc soutien psychologique je pense que
ça peut être utile parce que c'est vrai
que
je le vois moi au sein même de mon
équipe voilà ça quand même pas été
facile pour tous les élus parce que
c'est vrai que j'ai chance d'avoir une
équipe qui est très soudée et on a quand
même un certain nombre voilà qui ça
faisait peur qu'il le vivait pas très
bien donc même si j'étais là pour
essayer voilà de leur monter le moral
pour essayer de maintenir toute l'équipe
je pense que il y a sûrement des
personnes pour qui ça aurait pu être
difficile quand même de subir tout ça
probablement peut-être des mères qui
auraient peut-être démissionner avant
d'aller d'aller jusque là mais bon c'est
vrai que ça peut être important c'est
vraiment s'il y a un soutien
psychologique qui peut être proposé
justement pour essayer de pallier à
toutes ces toutes ces difficultés
pour répondre il est parti me demandait
mon confrère c'est que pensait ma
patientèle
un soutien total c'est vrai alors bien
entendu je pouvais pas tout raconter
parce que voilà
le manque de médecin même dans les
communes comme la mienne
voilà c'est c'est compliqué on a pas
trop de temps à perdre pour discuter
trop longtemps avec les avec les
patients mais il y avait quand même un
soutien important notamment au niveau de
ce projet de cada puisque tous les
brevinois mes patients aussi donc on
vécu toutes ces manifestations et quand
je vous disais qu'en fin de compte ce
qui était opposés c'est vraiment une
toute petite minorité c'est vraiment
quelques quelques personnes puisque tous
ceux qui manifestaient surtout étaient
en dehors de la commune et lorsque la
manifestation la contre manifestation
avait été organisée beaucoup de bruits
noirs dont des certaines mes patients
ils ont également participé donc
de ce côté là
n'avait pas de difficulté il y a une
question importante
sur le député
le soutien ou pas du député
mon prédécesseur
donc en 2017 c'est lui qui m'avait
demandé de prendre la suite
il y a eu on a eu quelques petites
quelques petites différences sur sur la
commune ce qui fait qu'en 2020 quand
j'ai décidé de me représenter il est
allé dans une liste opposée
[Rires]
que bon je voilà c'est son c'est son
droit bien entendu au niveau de jour de
l'incendie il ne m'a pas appelé
j'ai eu le droit pour communiquer
officielle qui l'a mis sur les sur les
réseaux
mon prédécesseur était pharmacien
et donc pendant
[Musique]
32 ans en fait en exerçant un
Saint-Brevin j'ai eu des relations
jusqu'à ce qu'il arrête ça sa profession
de pharmacien mais j'ai eu une relation
régulière avec lui en plus je
fournissais au niveau de mes fournitures
médicales dans sa pharmacie donc là le
côté humain voilà je l'ai pas vu
il y a
deux trois semaines nous avons inauguré
un EHPAD un nouvel EHPAD dans ma commune
j'ai rencontré il y avait le directeur
du département qui m'a demandé tout de
suite qui m'a demandé des nouvelles qui
a pris des nouvelles de moi également
c'est les vices présidents du
département monsieur le député qui était
présent que je n'avais pas vu depuis
longtemps en fait ma même pas demandé de
nouvelles et depuis
pas un mot donc je sais qu'il est
intervenu hier on est question
à l'Assemblée mais bon
donc j'en n'en dirai pas plus
[Musique]
on a eu le temps de réfléchir on a
laissé passer voilà le cap de façon à
pas prendre une décision comme ça dans
la foulée
j'ai bien réfléchi voilà avec mon épouse
avec mes enfants même s'ils ne vivent
plus à la maison mais enfin bon voilà
ils sont et
voilà maintenant
mes enfants me disent de tout arrêter ma
femme ne veut plus rester sur
Saint-Brevin et puisque pour l'instant
on ne sait pas la personne n'est
toujours pas arrêtée
donc c'est ce qu'elle me dit en faisant
mes courses si ça se trouve je le croise
il est peut-être en train de rigoler
dans mon dos une fois qu'il m'a croisé
donc plus ce qui s'est passé le week-end
dernier voilà on n'a pas envie donc ma
décision voilà je ne reviendrai pas en
arrière j'ai bien décidé j'avais un
autre projet que nous avions construit
avec mon épouse mais qu'on avait aux
avions prévu pour la fin du mandat de
toute façon j'avais décidé de ne pas me
présenter en 2026 ça faisait déjà trois
mandats
et donc bah ce projet nous allons
l'avancée et puis nous allons pouvoir en
profiter
les messages à faire passer l'exécutif
c'est vrai et quand j'ai eu le le préfet
le jour de mademnisation j'en ai parlé
quand même de tout cela puisqu'on a été
un petit bout de ton téléphone je lui
dis quand même du manque de soutien on
avait ressenti on s'était quand même
trouvé isolé
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'avais
marqué dans mon communiqué justement le
mode de soutien de l'État et c'est ce
que je lui ai dit il y a sûrement des
choses à faire
lui quand il est arrivé comme nouveau
préfet
bon il aurait peut-être pu faire
pourquoi pas au moins au niveau de la
Loire-Atlantique une réunion qui
permettrait de se présenter de
rencontrer des différents maires j'ai
bien qu'il peut pas aller dans les
différentes communes
là vu ce qu'on subissait il aurait pu
quand même essayer de voilà que l'on est
un peu plus de relations ne serait-ce
que par des coups de téléphone des
courriers et s'aperçu que il y avait
probablement un gros problème de
communication entre justement ce préfet
préfet et puis et puis les collectivités
alors que moi j'avais découvert que dans
d'autres dans d'autres départements
c'était pas du tout comme ça donc voilà
est-ce que ça vient de la personne et ce
que c'est difficile à dire mais quand je
me sois quand je vois que dans d'autres
départements où il y a vraiment une
relation entre les maires et les préfets
surtout que on a souvent entendu parler
que le couple important c'était quand
même préférée et là ma préférée peut pas
dire que je l'ai connu donc
si j'ai j'ai décidé d'aller jusque là et
puis d'aller jusqu'au bout et puis
devenir également ce matin
c'est parce que voilà j'ai pas envie que
ça se reproduit j'ai pas envie non plus
que pour les autres mères je vous dis
qu'ils m'ont qui m'ont adressé des
messages et qui subissent aussi voilà
des violences verbales ou physiques
voilà je crois qu'il faut que ça change
et on s'aperçoit que dans les
différentes propositions de loi qu'il y
a eu enfin de loin rien pour l'instant
on en a bougé donc mon souhait puisque
certains dit j'étais devenu un symbole
ma foi voilà si je peux au moins
terminer
cette carrière politique pour en
essayant d'avoir fait quelque chose et
puis d'avoir fait bouger les lignes pour
justement l'avenir et notamment pour les
élus parce que on s'aperçoit quand même
que les contraintes sont quand même de
plus en plus importantes et qui est-ce
qui est à ce contact avec les
concitoyens c'est avant tout c'est le
maire qui arrive là en premier et c'est
lui qui doit à tout prix défendre toutes
les décisions de l'État et on sait très
bien que c'est quand même pas simple
tout à l'heure j'ai cité en tout début
Lausanne je pense que ça va être
difficile voilà d'annoncer à certains
citoyens que voilà leur terrain on peut
plus les plus constructives on peut plus
rien faire déjà on s'aperçoit que dans
ces différentes lignes de de projet de
l'État
est-ce qu'il y a de la communication
bien pas forcément moi je sais que au
niveau de du pays de Ré avec mon
collègue mère Jean-Michel maire le maire
de Pornic on avait fait une conférence
de presse parce que on n'arrêtait pas
d'entendre on en a commune mais arrêtez
de bétonner arrêtez de bétonner dans les
centres-villes parce qu'il y a des
immeubles qu'est-ce qu'on construisent
pour essayer d'expliquer justement nos
concitoyens on applique on applique la
loi
on a essayé également moi je l'ai fait
au niveau de mon bulletin municipal tout
un dossier pour essayer d'expliquer
justement pour éviter d'être harcelé en
permanence ou d'être critiqué mais c'est
vrai que il y a peut-être des manques de
communication justement des différents
lois de l'exécutif pour faire comprendre
à nos concitoyens que c'est pas le maire
qui est responsable que lui
malheureusement il est obligé de subir
de faire appliquer la loi et d'essayer
de faire comprendre ces différents
messages et de les faire passer au
niveau des concitoyens
la nature au niveau du soutien des
des élus au niveau de
au niveau de la puce que je suis
également le président de
l'intercommunalité c'est vrai qu'on est
relativement soudé et c'est vrai que
tous mes tous mes collègues mères
étaient avec nous et justement en
parlant d'intercommunalité juste
également pour vous rappeler également
quelque chose en vous avez dû entendre
parler que nous avons eu nous la ZAD la
fameuse date du carnet puisque là aussi
encore une fois c'était un projet de
l'État qui voulait implanter vous savez
il y avait 12 sites
[Musique]
qui étaient prêts pour justement
industrialiser cette zone et donc cette
date s'est installé et jusqu'au jour où
forcément s'entraîner que vous imaginez
bien des des nuisances vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens qui habitaient pas très loin
et nous arrivions pas à voir de
rendez-vous avec le préfet donc c'est
pas celui qui est actuellement c'était
son prédécesseur Monsieur Didier Martin
comme nous n'arrivions pas avoir de
rendez-vous avec le préfet pour lui
demander quand est-ce qu'il allait
évacuer cette ZAD nous avons décidé un
jour les cimères il y avait également la
sénatrice Laurence tu étais là et puis
la conseillère départementale où nous
sommes rendus à la préfecture à Nantes
avec nos échappe pour avoir un
rendez-vous avec le préfet
nous n'avons pas eu de rendez-vous ils
nous ont envoyé la police
pour manifestation non déclaré
voilà donc nous sommes rentrés
sur notre territoire et nous avons
appris dans l'après-midi par la presse
que nous allions avoir un rendez-vous et
que nous avons eu deux semaines après où
nous sommes rendus à la préfecture
justement pour parler de cette
évaluation de lasagne donc encore une
fois même si cela ça n'avait rien à voir
avec avec le CADA mais ça montre bien
que il y avait quand même un décalage
voilà si cimer une sénatrice une
conseillère départementale voilà envoyer
la police pour manifestation non déclaré
c'est
sous-estimations des menaces c'était un
peu ce que je vous ai dit quand on a
reçu avec mes deux adjoines
le sous-préfet et commandant gendarmerie
ce qui nous a dit en fin de compte les
menaces mais non c'est rien puisqu'il
nous a dit mais moi aussi j'ai des
menaces parce que nous a dit le
sous-préfet
et oui mais c'était on lui a pourtant
bien dit vous savez également avec
toutes les menaces qu'il y a sur les
réseaux sociaux on lui a rappelé quand
même quelque chose ça a commencé comme
ça donc pour la faire de Samuel Pat